quarterback's starting for a different
team in week one because we're way
overgrown i'm gonna go sam darnold right
off the bat
okay i'm gonna go sam darling because i
like what i just said i mean everything
we've talked about with the draft
everything there
i i mean i'm i'm in love with zach
wilson i don't know
how the jets feel about it or whatever
but i'm gonna play that they
they take zach wilson and trade sam
darnold to somebody
uh so i'm gonna go sam darnold yeah
um man i i it's week one
i would say desean watson but week one
i don't know that this is gonna i'm
still gonna say deshaun watson i'm still
gonna say
they're they're going to realize wisdom
is going to show up it may take a little
while but i think before
because they're going to need a
quarterback if he's going to skip games
they're going to have to have another
plan or this year is going to be a
disaster for the texans so i'll go to
sean watson okay i like that um
i'm going to go well you know i'm just
going to connect the dots to what i just
said
and now i'm going to go to jimmy
garoppolo okay yeah i mean
the jets take zach wilson i
think there's a good chance with the
fact that it's mike lafleur and robert
sala
that sam darnold could go to the 49ers
right so i'm gonna say garoppolo
now is a new starter somewhere else
uh at some point during the year and i
don't know if that involves a three-team
trade or
just a separate trade altogether but
i'll go jimmy garoppolo as my second
my second pec here and i have no inside
info
or any crap about that okay i just we're
doing a draft
and there we go i i just don't know who
else would
make garoppolo their starter other than
the patriots maybe the houston texans
well maybe and and my next one's going
to be cam newton because i agree with
his assessment that there aren't 32
quarterbacks out there better than him
so ipso facto he'll be starting for
someone
other than the pa oh you boy now i think
if he
he's got a chance to start for the
patriots so i'm going out on a limb here
to say cam newton but i think one way or
another he's gonna be starting for
somebody this year yeah i hear you there
i mean cam's on my list too i
expect them to be with the patriots uh i
do but um yeah i hear you i think
there's still a chance that could be
somewhere else as well and i agree with
what he said too
my last one i'm i'm uh i'm gonna go with
russell wilson i'm gonna take it
i don't know you know again i know the
chances this is a fun draft
the chances are probably slim i don't
know but i do
think feel know that it's over in
seattle
so maybe at some point they just go well
okay we know it's over next year
so let's just get it over with right now
and move on and start building for the
future
i'm gonna go with my last pick to jameis
winston
um because again there are so many
unsettled quarterback situations out
there
and i i think that that it would be
not all that difficult for a team that's
in need of a quarterback to convince
itself that
they can get the good out of jameis and
minimize the bad
and sean payton praising the guy
and if he decides we know what taysom
hill
has at least an inside track and the
saints don't have the money to pay me
i'm a free agent someone else is
offering me more
uh you know who knows i mean if the
seahawks move on from russell wilson
they need a starting quarterback and i'm
not saying they would rush to jameis but
at least he'd be on the list
this idea that the seahawks can only
trade
russell wilson to a team that would
trade a quarterback back to them
right it's a little it's a little bit
goofy because there are other ways to
fill your need
you can't just say well we're only going
to trade him to a team that has a
quarterback that we want well
then you're never going to trade him so
i just think there'll be an opportunity
for jameis out there somewhere yeah
there could be i know i mean unless i
thought about taysom hill just because
of that aspect and maybe something like
that you know
tua was on my list as well as a guy that
maybe he's somewhere else if the miami
dolphins do get to sean watson maybe tua
ends up in houston
so uh all possibilities this it's a
fascinating year as far as the
quarterback's concerned
i'm excited to see where it all goes and
flushes out here over the next five six
weeks
i thought about drew locke too but i
don't know where he would be the starter
now yeah right
it's amazing how that star has kind of
fallen for him yep
no it's uh he would he would scare me to
trade for
that's for to be a starter definitely
there's some talent there we know that
but as we discussed during the year
it's just too loose too many aggressive
overly aggressive decisions
and doing things like that it's a big
year for drew lock if he's still the guy
in denver he's gonna really have to hone
it in
and play smarter football if he wants to
survive as a starting quarterback in the
nfl
and the other thing to remember there
could be three four five maybe six
rookies who get plugged into the lineup
right away somewhere which would take
spots away from
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports